all right October is domestic violence
Awareness Month safe nest and
Intermountain Healthcare are teaming up
to stop what is an epidemic joining us
to talk about their efforts to stop
domestic violence we have Liz
ortenberger who is the CEO of safe nest
and Kerry palakanus who is from
Intermountain Healthcare thank you both
for joining us today at palacanus I've
practiced that beforehand and still
messed it up thank you both for joining
us today let's talk about some of the
efforts you have going on as this is
domestic violence awareness month what
are some of the key things that you have
done teaming up together yeah so
Intermountain has been incredibly
generous with safeness and actually
helped us launch the coaching boys into
men and athletes As Leaders program two
years ago which we have got intensive
work going on in Charter and private
schools throughout the valley helping
coaches understand how they can have
conversations of consequence with the
young men and young women in their
locker rooms I love that and Cara you
guys have done studies that show that
this plays into overall health when it
comes to two families absolutely
unfortunately domestic violence intimate
partner violence is a symptom of the
dysfunction that occurs in the social
dynamics in families and without
organizations like safeness our
individuals in our community would be
lost
and it is it is heartening to hear Liz
that they're we're working on the ground
floor here with kids who obviously are
going to into adulthood and will
eventually be in such situations because
the role models have not been fantastic
sometimes when it comes to athletes no
and the stats are really clear 76
percent of kids growing up in households
where domestic violence is present are
going to repeat that cycle as victim or
as abuser that's the generational
studies that we look at and so really
ending domestic violence starts with
young people the coaching boys into men
and athletes As Leaders program 95
percent of the young people in sports
will be leaders in companies and in our
communities in the future empowering
them with understanding their context as
young people but also the changes they
can make in their workplaces in their
communities as adults this is how we
start to end generationally these Trends
and it is sobering to find out how
ubiquitous domestic violence is you have
done studies on that as well yes yeah
it's across our Valley 43 of women have
been affected by domestic violence 37
percent of men on the Survivor side on
the victim side of that we know many
more men have been affected and women as
abusers as well and so really working
with Intermountain allows us to start to
create a holistic approach particularly
looking at things like strangulation and
those some of those determinants that
could have lifelong effects for Survivor
but are going fairly undetected today
well thank you both for your efforts and
we really appreciate you being here
today thank you thank you very much we
want to thank Intermountain Healthcare
for sponsoring this segment if you'd
like more information you can visit
safenest.org and
intermountainhealthcare.org forward
slash Nevada we'll be right back